si eres para ti y luego la rueda de
prensa emitida por parte del alto mando
militar a cargo del ministro de la
defensa luís lara aseguraba que en la
democracia en este país está altamente
en riesgo y también sucede luego que el
presidente de república emitiera un
nuevo estado de sesión que se extiende a
seis provincias del país esto también ha
ocasionado la respuesta por parte de los
movimientos indígenas que rechazan que
se les criminalice y llama inclusive a
respetar la función que realizan los
medios de comunicación quienes han
vivido también algún tipo de ataque
también rechazan que se les criminalice
este sentido también llegaron la noche
de ayer a la ciudad de quito y a la
ciudad de guayaquil y la ciudad de quito
amanece como puedes ver yo me encuentro
en medio de una autopista es que los
principales accesos de la ciudad capital
al menos 20 acceso de la ciudad capital
como he dicho la autoridad municipal se
encuentran cerrados y esto obliga a que
las personas deban desviarse o inclusive
deban caminar largas distancias para
poder llegar a su destino hace algunos
minutos por aquí también transitaron en
distintos convoyes militar la fuerza
militar se mantiene en este momento en
las calles ante manifestaciones que no
muy lejos de aquí se producen en este
momento el presidente a república ha
sido enfático en sostener que estas
movilizaciones pretenden derrocarlo del
poder él ha dicho que no seguirá que se
mantienen en el palacio de gobierno y
los movimientos indígenas rechazan este
tipo de aseveraciones
responsabilizándole de las intenciones
que
adelante al grupos en grupos y
movimientos sociales lo cierto es que
los movimientos indígenas ya se
encuentran en la ciudad de quito
arribaron la noche de ayer también y
regresaron a una casa de estudios se
mantiene en este momento en la
universidad central del ecuador donde
aspiran descansar tal y como ha dicho
pero se ratifica que continúan las
movilizaciones en el ecuador estaba
hablando del presidente que implica este
nuevo estado de excepción
pero la aplicación de un nuevo estado de
decepción implica que se mantiene
durante los próximos 30 días y se podrá
ver a las fuerzas militares en el país
se mantiene también lo que ha sido este
despliegue militar y se suspenden a sus
derechos
establecidos en la carta magna por
cuanto el derecho a la inviolabilidad
del hogar también se modificó el derecho
al acceso libre acceso a la información
este derecho fue modificado en un nuevo
decreto el ejecutivo nacional ha emitido
al menos varios decretos y ley deroga un
decreto y emitido un nuevo decreto por
el cual también la asamblea nacional
también ha rechazado ha cuestionado esta
manera de manejar este estado de
movilizaciones que existe en el país
ayer por lo menos la asamblea nacional
se proponía a derogar el decreto
presidencial pero no fue sino antes de
que el presidente de la república
derogar al decreto y emitiera un nuevo
decreto así que en este momento esta
situación ya genera reacciones de
distintos sectores en el país raúl